the date reads the 23rd of February the
eve of Russia's War and the last time
children in this Village came to class
ES
blast waves cause damage but the school
stood firm becoming a place of safety
instead of study as Russian forces took
over sneharivka in southern Ukraine
the deputy headmistress showed us the
basement where families took shelter
oh wow
so how many people slept here she said
it was around 400 adults and children
some only came at night others stayed
all the time
the last two guests only ventured home a
couple of days earlier more than a week
after Ukrainian troops liberated The
Village as part of a major
counter-offensive
and how how does it feel coming back
here now
foreign
[Music]
the focus now is on repairing the damage
and at some point reopening
on a nearby Street more trauma yeah
Lydia shows me where some kind of
munition hit her home a few weeks back
it knocked the 82 year old off her feet
banging her head
foreign
is a common theme across Ukraine even as
the war rages on
reconstruction underway on this bridge
in the town of erpin on the outskirts of
Kiev
it was destroyed as Russian forces tried
and failed to capture the capital back
in March
on Monday a school in this town will
finally reopen for the first time after
being repaired
English classes among those ready to
start
um
but even as pupils return they'll be on
alert for new attacks the reality of War
a classroom feature Deborah Haynes Sky
News Urban